[Music]  little Northwest is making our hearts  explode with her cuteness the famous  four year old has already starred in her  daddy Kanye West's only one music video  I talked to God about he said he sent  you an angel look at already now she's  proving she may have inherited his  musical talent too he or she snuggles up  to mama Kim Kardashian while serenading  her the 36 year old reality stars  sharing the sweet clip on snapchat  Monday if you look closely you'll notice  North is sporting and in memory of alia  t-shirt in the video and she appears to  get a bit camera shy towards the end now  singing isn't little North East only  musical gift  Tim shared this clip in March proving  her daughter's violin skills are totally  on point